joining me today is a writer and
activist and the founder of theory of
Enchantment dot-com
Chloe Valerie welcome to the Rubin
report thank you I'm very happy to have
you here because you are one of I don't
know I'd say 12 people online that don't
make me completely insane like I look at
your Twitter feed and I'm like oh
there's someone with the brain that's
actually not completely insane Thanks so
actually we met a couple months ago in
September at a Jordan Peterson event yes
would you say that was the best white
supremacist event you were yeah before
we get into your history and everything
else and you're doing you're doing truly
so much great work what do you make of
the Peterson phenomenon because so many
of my guests I'm finding or coming to
shows and it's like it's pretty cool I
understand like fundamentally I
understand what he's doing I think that
I think that he is compelling to many
people because in many cases he's a
storyteller he's a great storyteller and
what he can do is he can distill lessons
from stories stories found in pop
culture stories that are history and and
derive lessons that you can apply to
your life and I think that anyone who
can do that will be compelling because
they can actually better your life and I
think that's the secret as to why he's
so popular and also I've noticed that
he's be I think he's becoming more
mainstream I think he's becoming more
acceptable into in mainstream society
which is it which is a positive trend
like seeing him being interviewed on dr.
oz for example was like a moment I think
of him inching closer and closer to the
mainstream what's that phrase first they
ignore you then they mock you and then
they want to be you something like that
so you may be in that version yeah all
right well speaking of stories tell me a
little bit about your story who the hell
are you oh yes I am Chloe
I'm from New Orleans originally born and
raised my story I guess is an
interesting one I was born and raised in
a very atypical Christian family
a typical in the sense that I grew up as
a Christian observing Shabbat yeah so so
what is that what is that so the way I
like to tell it is you know have you
heard of seventh-day adventists I have
so it's like seventh-day Adventists but
on steroids
essentially that's how I grew up so
seventh-day adventists um my
understanding they keep Shabbat that's
why they call them the seventh day so
they go to church on Saturday so Sunday
so we did that also but we also did
things like we observed Yom Kippur and
Rosh Hashanah in all the Jewish holy
days and we also kept kosher styles so I
don't eat pork or shellfish and that
wasn't interesting upbringing I have two
funny stories to tell you the first is
about Yom Kippur yeah so as I'm sure you
know in the Jewish tradition
Oh once or twice right yeah so can you
tell me what age one begins fasting for
Yom Kippur well there's an obvious
answer here that obviously can't be the
right answer but I would assume 13 okay
yeah okay okay okay
well my parents didn't have their
binnacle texts to advise them on like
what age they should make their kids
start fasting and so for some reason
they decided that five years old
oh good time to so I've been fasting for
Yom Kippur since I was five oh man so
yeah so you're an old pro now yes yes so
that's like one quick story of how I
grew up in and my father introduced me
to the writings of Leon URIs when I was
15 years old so he was a really famous
Jewish off there who got a lot about the
reestablishment of the State of Israel
he wrote books like Exodus and qb7 and
millet 18 and I read all these books
throughout high school and it was part
of the Hebrew culture Club in high
school when it's a very egalitarian high
school in New Orleans yeah so this is
sort of my introduction to the world of
Jewish culture but also Israel and a
contemporary sense yeah and then I
attended the University of New Orleans
where I initially majored in film but
then switch made
to International Studies 2012 graduated
magna [ __ ] laude yes yeah but the reason
why I switched majors was because
anti-semitism was resurfacing in Europe
in in France in particular yeah so this
is about what seven eight years ago this
is 2012 yeah okay yeah so and I wanted
to get involved in the Israel space so
that's why I switched majors and I
started a student pro-israel
organization on campus that is where
advocacy for three and a half years
realized that we didn't know what we
were doing but I learned a lot from that
experience and that was my college
experience yeah okay so we're gonna get
to obviously a lot of the advocacy work
that you do and some of the things that
you've written and all that but just a
little bit more on the on the growing up
part cuz there's something really
fascinating there it's like it's sort of
for you it's like oh well this is how I
grew up you're kind of Israel but it
sounds for other people it's like wait a
minute so she's Christian but was
celebrating all these Jewish holidays
like how was that explained to you as a
child or is was it explained yeah it was
like it was like the explanation was
this is how Jesus and the disciples
observed so we're gonna observe in this
way that was like the basic explanation
and then like she's growing up you know
you're conditioned to do these things
and so it just becomes rote and becomes
like basic but like you were saying it
doesn't make sense a lot of people
looking from the outside in so yeah yeah
okay so College you started realizing
that that the things that you had grown
up around that something was sort of
under assault sort of is that fair to
say yeah I think yeah and I think that
because you know anti-semitism is
fundamentally like dehumanization of
Jews and because I had grown up with
such a not just a like a love for the
Jewish people but an awareness of Jewish
culture like to a certain extent I've my
identity was defined by Jewish culture
or adjacent to Jewish culture so I think
in that sense it did feel like something
a part of me was under attack so that
was probably a huge catalyst for getting
involved what did the like your Jewish
friends think about this girl that you
know doesn't Sarah typically look Jewish
which is
listening to say of course because there
are black Jews and Pinot Jews and
Chinese Jews and everything else did
your friends think like what is this
thing in college college growing up with
it whatever it is well growing up it I
don't I don't know if they if they saw
any different I don't remember I just
remember that the Jewish kids and myself
were not in school during Rosh Hashanah
we were just out of we were just absent
at the same time yeah in college I just
made all my pretty good if you want a
couple extra days off very good very
good
I mean I didn't even talk about you
could story but in college my friend I
just made my friends join my club so
they like I just made them me I think
there was no like oh this is it was just
who I was and like a part of you know my
life yeah so it seems to me that right
now
I guess campus anti-semitism is sort of
running rampant I think it has a lot to
do with BDS and we can talk about that
and more but what were you actually
seeing back then that were the markers
yeah I mean back then so there wasn't a
lot of there wasn't like systemic
anti-semitism at the University of New
Orleans or for example at Tulane where I
did a lot of pro-israel stuff also but
actually what I discovered was though
there was anti-semitism on certain
campuses certain hotbed campuses like
Columbia and UC Irvine and we've heard
about all these different campuses where
they're you know problems
the larger issue was that we in the
community were confusing to different
things
we were confusing two very important
questions with each other the first
question was how do you combat
anti-semitism which is a noble question
a good question a question that got me
involved with a question of how do you
actually get people to fall in love with
Israelis and we were confusing those two
questions and as a result we were coming
we were we were shaping the basis of our
advocacy around the wrong assumptions so
like the first question how do you fight
anti-semitism is essentially a question
of how do you get people to stop hating
but the second question how do you get
people to fall in love with Israelis or
Israeli society it's a question of how
do you get people to start loving
different question and we we and I say
like collectively we the per original
community in America hadn't figured that
out and so as a result we were doing
pro-israel advocacy or we're putting
together projects within the realm of
protest or advocacy that didn't make
sense
yeah and that was the larger trend that
I observed that I witnessed when I was
in college all right so let's do both of
those so first how do you deal with
disassembling anti-semitism or just
hatred in general well I think so I
think they're interconnected on some
level I think it's not just enough to to
continue to tell people to stop hating
obviously that's important but you also
have to create a framework and create
sort of like a collection of lessons if
you will on how to start loving on how
to love if you will I'm a so I saw that
I think that that actually ends up
combating anti-semitism and combating
all forms of hatred if you actually
build out a framework or try to teach
people how to love do you think there's
something unique about hating Jews
that's a little bit different than
hating other people like sort of partly
a historical reason yeah because it goes
back forever basically but also that I
find right now I mean most of the people
that hate me you're on the left let's
say so I get a relentless amount of hate
from them and I don't I don't get a lot
of hate from the right but every now and
again when I get a hate hatred from the
right it's you blah blah blah that kind
of thing yeah it's for in my case it's
very disproportionate on one side and
that probably has more to do with my
politics right now but I do think it's
interesting that it's sort of it is that
horseshoe theory where the people on the
fringes both end up hating you for
identity right that's a good question I
think different I mean if you were to
look at intersectionality for example
which is this I was hoping we'd get to
it
yeah favorite yeah let's do it can you
explain let's it let's let's steal man
intersectionality give me give me what
the the person out there that's the
believer in intersectionality what what
would they tell you intersectionality is
before we knock it down
right I think I can still man it I mean
I'd say that intersectionality
makes three claims one of which is true
the first claim that it makes is that
you can you can experience intersecting
forms of oppression so I as both a woman
and a person of color can experience
forms of oppression by virtues of those
categories to which I belong and they
can interest intersect and interact with
each other in new ways for the record
I've been conducting this interview as
if you were a white man I just want to
be clear I'm trying out there thank you
so much okay but you've got these you've
got these two immutable characteristics
basically that could intertwine based in
their outsider characteristics right
right so like a person a man could be
sexist toward me or a white person could
be racist to me right and then and then
both of those types of discriminations
or prejudices can interact in different
ways which i think is a basically true
statement okay so that is the extent to
which I can still manage your sexuality
okay now give me the nod then all right
they're not so true and actually it was
a dangerously false claims of
intersectionality one is that the
primary motivator behind all human
interaction is power mm-hmm
and by power they mean like that power
in order to oppress so I could be having
a disagreement political disagreement
with you in good faith but according to
the intersectional lists it doesn't
matter because you have white skin and I
have brown skin and so you by virtue of
the category that you exist in you are
trying to oppress me right and in this
case my gayness would fall below the
importance of say my white skin exactly
an intersection on the scale of
intersectionality Jewishness is
completely sort of thrown out which i
think is related to the Israel thing
which while you talk definitely like
hierarchies of what like virtues and
stuff like that or lack thereof in your
case
yeah I'm just me but can I tell you so
that's the that's the first dangerous
claim that it makes and then the second
conclusion I guess you would say to
which it comes is a conclusion of ratio
essentialist
so what that means is you could take any
human basic human behavior let's say
feeling entitled right so my friend
could have a new iPhone X and for some
reason like I don't have the money to
buy the iPhone X but I want the iPhone X
whatever I'm coveting right yeah this
iPhone X if you will so I feel a sense
of entitlement to it right so any human
being can feel a sense of entitlement
right that's my point but the
intersectional list will will claim that
entitlement like a priori is the white
man's thing so they will refer to
entitlement as white male entitlement as
if the only type of human being that can
feel or express a behavior of
entitlement is a white male and so in
doing that they are racially
essentializing people they are taking
human behaviors and turning them into
essential characteristics of people that
belong to one category so as somebody
that comes from a unique religious
perspective what do you make of the
religious nature the people that buy
into this ideology it's a good question
I mean it's it's like like many
religions it is all-encompassing like
many will certainly like certain I would
say mainstream forms of Christianity it
sort of preaches this born-again type
mentality where you become woke rain
which is just another word for
enlightened no but like the parallels
are like you've become right born again
you've become the problem one of the
many problems is that there's no
salvation there's no redemption in this
religion you get brownie points or
virtue points if you are if you belong
to certain categories like if you're a
person of color if you're a woman etc
and you get less points if you're white
if you're male if you're straight etc
etc and what this does is it has a
character cheering effect on on human
beings where people are reduced to
caricatures it creates this effect where
the people who are intersectional is and
who believe in this theory are so
capable of dealing with nuance and
dealing with depth and human complexity
which is sad not just for the people
that they're attacking but for
themselves do you think it's an overstep
to call it the new type of racism
because I'm really coming around to that
really yeah like I'm like right there on
that I've said it once or twice I don't
really like saying it because I don't I
don't want to start using the tactics
which I hate so much right of course I
don't want to do that but I don't know
if you saw my episode with her in August
I had Catherine Birbal sing who's a
wonderful teacher at Michaela school in
the UK and she flat out and she's a
brown-skinned and the whole thing but
she doesn't buy into any this nonsense
and she was adamant in saying this is
the new racism and we must call it that
and I agree with the heart of the
sentiment and I just adore her and ice
that was I spoke at school a couple
weeks ago but but I'm a little leery of
why are you Lee really because I don't
want to fall into the same trap that
they've come in where every time I hear
one of their arguments the idea would be
that I could just turn to them and be
like well you're the new races you know
where cuz it's just right and shut it
down it's so easy and lazy and the rest
of it so I don't I don't want to do that
and yet if I see the way the world is
now where I see true racism coming from
it's almost exclusively coming from
these people I'm not saying that there
aren't some white nationalists there are
some they have no power nobody cares
about them they're mocked and they're
actually propped up by the media to make
it seem like they're running the world
but where I see true racism coming from
these days and a true hatred based on
immutable characteristics is this set of
intersectional woke people I just don't
want to be I just don't want to be that
right I think that from my purposes I
don't just want to like I want to
criticize in a meaningful way so I would
have to ask the question well I get
people who believe in intersectional as
theory to change or convince them to
change simply by calling them racist
probably not probably not right and it's
not when they call all these people on
the right
they call basic conservatives or
libertarian it's not like they're coming
around
I am woke I am now boarding it no it
doesn't work though yeah so so I think I
would rather challenge people who
believe in this theory on their own
terms do you get a unique read to do
that because yes you're so how does that
how does that how does that work that
you could almost use their own crappy
thing against them in a bizarre way even
though you don't believe in it there's a
unique power there I suppose but I think
but I think what I do is I convey depth
meaning I think I am an example of human
complexity so on the surface level I am
using their own hierarchy of virtuous
people or virtuous types against them
but at the same time I think I'm showing
them what that human complexity actually
exists
because I disagree with them so it's
like a cognitive dissonance thing that
they have to figure out but I'm more
interested in people in in trying to
challenge people who believe in this
especially young people would say this
is on college campuses and such to
become better people and I have to in
order to do that I have to criticize
them in a way that actually speaks to
their potential to be better people I
mean I'm like I said I'm not gonna
accomplish that by calling them races
but what I can do is try to I can try to
for example point them to I think
authors and people in literature for
example who they highly esteem whose
work they don't quite yet realize is not
intersectional so who might that be
Maya Angelou for example I think that
there is a very stark contrast between
like Tommy Vesey Coates in Maya Angelou
mm-hmm the very first poet I was forced
to memorize as a child was Maya Angelou
and so like I feel like I I carry her
spirit with me and the way she talks
about human complexity and the way she
talks about how no bling the human
spirit is is in many ways a contrast to
intersectional Astari she famously one
time said that Shakespeare must have
been a black woman because and because
like one of his
it's she she felt so closely and
intimately connected to in the struggles
that she was going going through as a
child and her point was that all of this
literature if it even if it comes from
like let's say the dead white male right
was written for all of you for each of
you and you can see yourself in that in
the stories that these great writers
created and that's the point that's what
makes them great writers is the fact
that you can see yourself in them so I
would point people toward especially her
work because they typically and
generally esteem her and they consider
her to be an icon and I think she was an
icon open to them that can use that to
actually teach them well here's an
alternative way of thinking actually and
what you're learning in your post
structuralist class about like human
life in human affairs isn't necessarily
true and it isn't it isn't the only
thing out there what do you make of the
fact that it seems like so many young
people are going to college so ill
prepared to deal with the world as it is
that they become so religious in nature
when it comes to this stuff like if they
had been given better tools perhaps some
of the things that Jordan Peterson's
talking about that they could go into
school and be challenged and be okay
with it as opposed to going in and
converting right I guess that's a parent
problem it's a parent and a parent yeah
yeah I mean I think I think it's a
question of upbringing obviously but I
also think I think that maybe it
signifies that students are searching
for meaning I mean students are
searching for meaning I was searching
for meaning in college you know we're
searching for meaning all of our lives
right and then what does it say that
that the only thing that seemingly out
there that's giving the meaning at least
it within the college context is
intersectional list theory I mean like
surely we as a society can do better
than that but I think that Jordan
Peterson represents is this contrast cuz
he is getting a lot of Fame and
popularity is considered to be popular
among some people many people in college
probably so I think that in that sense
maybe they're not being as converted as
as much as as much as
it seems they are yeah there is a there
is a battle of ideas of the hearts and
minds of these students yeah well
there's I mean there's definitely
statistical evidence that that's true
right there was that study that came out
a couple months ago that basically only
8% of young people actually are these
hysterical shrieking intersection list
but because they're so loud they're just
silencing the majority so that's that's
encouraging well so that means it's our
fault because right well that's what I
always say people every event I go
you're not being loud enough really well
that's the funny thing it's like every
literally every event I go to from the
Petersons event that you were at in Long
Island to all Atilla when I do stand-up
gigs whatever it is people come up to me
every time they go what can I do what
can I do and the only thing that I can
come up with that has any meaning
whatsoever is start speaking right like
you live in the freest society in the
history of the world and you're afraid
to say what you think yeah how would you
be in one of the bad places we all have
our own media companies like anything is
possible yeah so yeah I think I think we
need to start speaking more but I also
think we need to like I said earlier we
need to emphasize like it's not enough
to tell people how to stop hating we
also teach them how to start loving and
I think that that's something that needs
to be developed further also all right
so let's put the start love and part on
hold for a minute because that seems
like a good ending point for me so let's
put that to the end okay I've noticed
you you've been pretty critical about
what's going on in the women's March and
we're and I think we're starting to see
which I think is positive that this
intersectional sort of hierarchy or
monster I think it's a better word that
it can't hold very long and I think
we're seeing the evidence of that now
can you explain a little bit of why that
is
I've had a crazy couple days okay so all
this time you know we have this
suspicion that the leaders in the
women's March including Tameka Mallory
Linda Sarsour and Carmen Perez were sort
of like pretty like anti-semite
anti-semitic like hobnobbing with
Farrakhan and posting very positive
remarks about Farrakhan on their social
media platforms right when you say we
you mean
like us and yeah sort of sorry whatever
you want to call that subset of people
not not what mainstream portrays them
too sure but I'd say I'd say that this
has been a concern in the Jewish
community by and large for a very long
time like the majority of Jews in this
country are pro-israel right and so they
so collectively the pro-israel community
has had a sweeping suspicion about these
women's and tensions when it come when
they came to allowing Jews to march or
like telling you to have a safe place to
march or even a space to March and the
women's March and I'm actually part of a
organization called Zionists which tries
to give a space to progressive Jewish
women to march in these women's in these
women's market even though Linda Sarsour
shouting at them you there's no room for
you here yeah so the idea is like oh
you're not gonna give us a table we'll
build our own table what but what's
interesting is that yesterday this
bombshell report came out in televising
and our worst suspicions were confirmed
I did see a little bit us actually about
the security and everything else yeah so
go ahead so apparently I'll say
allegedly literally at the very first
meeting with these women who were being
added to as I guess as co-chairs to the
women's March there was there were
anti-semitic statements made about Jews
and and consistently throughout their
time as co-chairs there was a legend
they've allegedly been hiring security
folks from the Nation of Islam
Farrakhan's Nation Nation of Islam for
those of you who may be watching who
don't know Farrakhan has famously
referred or infamously refer to Jews as
termites I mean he's a notorious
anti-semite yeah so it turns out he's on
Twitter no problem is Twitter right down
below right exactly so these women have
been hiring security guards from the
Nation of Islam to do their security
detail at the Women's March and so it's
a really bombshell report I encourage
your viewers to read it but yeah we
actually will link to it okay
and that's a fair against but we will
put a link to the article yeah yeah and
it is like a it's it's a it's a crazy
moment so so does this seem like it
obvious to you in a way like it sort of
seems obvious to me that that about two
three years ago there were a bunch of us
I think sort of old school decent
liberals that were like this thing this
marriage in hell between the women's
March and Sarsour like this thing can't
hold of course this is going to happen
right so like I think there's a little
bit of like I told you so right for some
of us but that doesn't make you feel any
better right though it's not like you're
like aha Nostradamus over here right I
mean I guess one just holds that people
who are leaders would have the integrity
and responsibility and introspection to
not do this so what do you think has to
happen then for the woman's March to
move forward with with whatever the
goodness of that is right I think well
we're excited I'm not marching in any
March affiliated with the women's March
Inc which is which is the organization
that those women sit on the board of so
I'm just not gonna and there are other
marches there there are other individual
marches that have actually cut ties with
women's March Inc that people can still
March with if they feel so inclined but
as far as that particular organization
is concerned I'm not I'm not marching
with them anymore
so is the inherent problem of sort of
just collectivism as a ideology that to
say a woman's March is inherently sort
of ridiculous because well because
everyone's for when it's a very as
Jordan would say it's a low-resolution
argument everyone would say that you're
for women right like no one's not for
women or for women to be equal not
nobody but by-and-large any sane member
of society is not for women to be equal
in a Western society at least but when
you say you're for women what you're
always gonna do is exclude the minority
women so in this case forget forget skin
color even although this is a this is a
minority skin color I suppose the
women's March organizers they're not for
nikki Haley they're not Forrest
conservative woman who happens to have
brown skin but we've been forgetting her
skin color they're not for Sarah
Huckabee Sanders they're they're not for
any woman that doesn't believe in the
ideology so you're saying here for women
you mean that women who behave right
that's an interesting I I think I think
I slightly disagree with with the if you
specify the demographic that you are
marching on behalf then you are
necessarily not including other other
people in that category it happens to be
the case well I would say maybe it's the
fact they own maybe not intended like
the function of it ultimately I think I
think I don't think there's anything
wrong with with outlining like on whose
behalf they're marching I do take the
point that that but I think that this
this has been true of women's marches if
you will throughout throughout the like
since the suffrage movement like even
within the South the women's suffrage
movement there was there was a lot of
there were a lot of tensions because for
example it was the thing who was the
most famous one Susan yes yes okay so
there was a dispute between susan b
anthony if I have my facts correct
fact-checking on this oh there's a
dispute photo why this is because
YouTube belt back Jack yeah don't worry
there's a dispute between susan b
anthony and another woman whose name of
course I forget at this moment and the
reason was that susan b anthony was
actually willing to hobnob with people
who are racist in order to to get the
vote passed and this other woman who had
who was one of the founders of the
suffrage is moment had this falling out
with her because she was like you cannot
associate with you know these people who
are trying to to undermine another
demographic in the country and so I say
all that to say that I think that there
will always be these tensions within
these mass movements especially if if
you read this article that came out
inside the magazine especially if from
the especially if you are rooted in the
intersessional is framework I think that
that's the issue I think that you what
you might be able to see nikki Haley and
some of the other women you mentioned if
it wasn't actually rooted in
intersectionality on the other hand what
miss March is a progressive is a
self-proclaimed progressed progressive
organization progressive movement and so
by virtue of that they're not going to
include Republican women right so I
guess that's it name is a bit of a
misnomer so that's what it is i think
because i would argue that being for
progressivism as it stands in 2018 is
not being for women so i guess it's a
little bit of that and so i think that
if you were if you were to come across
the progressive march like a decade ago
yeah sure look very different from
holland as well so that's actually a
perfect segue how is this all connected
to whatever is going on with feminism
right now do you think do you consider
yourself a feminist i know it's a it's a
label that people are sort of scared of
now they either embrace it and they're
not sure why or they're very scared of
it or yeah i don't really have this like
knee-jerk viscerally like self disgusts
where the term feminism i feel like many
people certainly on the right are
increasingly having that that reaction i
understand why like if you if third wave
feminism is rooted in intersectionality
then like like I believe in feminism as
a basic like idea you know I love the I
love the work of Camille Paglia mhm so
so to that extent I'm definitely
actually fighting this for a long time
but I think like basic if you believe in
like equality for women and basically a
latarian ism to the extent that that is
feminism I am a feminist I don't I don't
need to like a dot all the other
frameworks that third wave feminism is
adopting now to consider myself Phyllis
I'd say yeah so let's just back up
slightly to what you were saying about
these competing sort of methods and how
people do things so susan b anthony was
willing to talk to some people this
other woman was and i mean we've seen
this in all sorts of movements martin
luther king yeah behaved a certain way
talk to certain people Malcolm X had a
different view of it so you view that as
sort of a necessary sort of push and
pull on how
movement is built well yeah I mean I
think I think that whether I believe in
it or not that is what that is how
movements have built I think especially
if you look at the Martin Luther King
vs. Malcolm X the economy it's much more
interesting because I was actually just
talking to a friend about this I don't
think people realize how difficult it
was in the 60s to buy into in practice
dr. King's philosophy like we take it
for granted in 2018 you don't know a lot
of people don't do it now in a wallet
right yes but I think that makes sense
because we're ironically privileged
that's a good title for a book
ironically privilege yeah yeah but
people don't realize that these these
these guys were training themselves not
to fight back when they were being when
when they were having you know like
condiments poured on them in diners like
that's hard it's a to root your belief
in the idea that I am NOT going to fight
back because these white people were
made in the image of God is a profoundly
crazy belief and my crazy I mean like
groundbreaking incredibly difficult to
actually put into practice right noble
beautiful and I saw so I think that has
to be understood when we contrast or
juxtapose Malcolm X with dr. King I
think that if you were to read Malcolm
X's autobiography and what happened to
him and this is important because people
need to understand why the Nation of
Islam has assert to a certain extent and
to a certain degree of hold in the black
community the Nation of Islam at the
time that Malcolm X was alive was
literally taking young black men who at
this point for example in Harlem were
addicts were junkies and turning them
into men of upstanding society right and
so in order to in order to counter the
toxic and deleterious effects of the
Nation of Islam we have to reckon and we
have to be willing to accept and
acknowledge that fact right the problem
is that that process of empowerment was
also deeply rooted in a very toxic
ideology
namely hating white people and by hating
white people let me be very clear
because I feel like people don't know
the extent to which the Nation of Islam
is crazy because of this issue
bring it the Nation of Islam believes
that white people are actually like like
not fully evolved like that they are
actually subhuman and that during the
time are you talking to a termite over
here exactly exactly like but like
actually and and that during the time of
the what would you call it messianic age
that's like why people will be destroyed
and people of color will take their
proper place in the hierarchy of I don't
know the great circle of life so it's
not it's not some like it's not just
simply oh you you were very like people
who were white were historically very
harmful to war black people so that's
why we don't like them no no it's an
intrusion baby I think like ideology
rooted in literally thinking why people
are subhuman and it's interesting
because people people will on the one
hand like in the in on the same at the
same time people will praise Malcolm X
and praise the Nation of Islam without
even recognizing that Malcolm X was
killed by the Nation of Islam had
disavowed the Nation of Islam by the
time he went to Mecca right and came
back and they're not willing to wrestle
with with the nuances of of that
particular movement seriously but I feel
like but you recognize the power of that
obviously right the power of sort of
just an easy answer to that yes that's
what is easy it's certain right and it's
very difficult for people to live with
uncertainty which i think is something
that the right needs to recognize and
needs to grapple with when it is
rightfully criticizing things like
intersectionality right there is an
attraction in being certain right
because if you have to deal with
uncertainty if you have to accept
uncertainty as a factor of life that's
very difficult we have like five
flight brains no right we're not we're
not evolved to deal with uncertainty on
some level or to be comfortable with
uncertainty and yet it's the almost the
only certainty right right
paradoxically yeah yes yes but that is
that I think also speaks to why
intersexuality
it's so attractive because it gives
people a way to anchor their
insecurities into something that is
steadfast so when you see people using
some of the language that the
intersectional lists are the woke crew
buy into so for example a couple weeks
ago Jamel Hill formerly of ESPN now of
the Atlantic she tweeted out the Jordan
Petersons a white supremacist and
misogynist so why do you know it gets
twenty thousand retweets or something
right wasn't he just speaking to the
Seattle Seahawks okay this is what I
meant by the way what I said mainstream
like that's awesome if it continues I'm
glad you brought that up because that
was the genesis of the tweet right
because it was about that Pete Carroll
the coach of the Seahawks had let white
supremacists and misogynist Jordan
Peterson talked to the team then another
ESPN guy picks it up then she tweets it
out so of course I just invited her I
said you know what I'm on tour with the
guy welcome yeah I said you're welcome I
didn't even say you what you wanted to
bait him nothing I just said I would
love to have you as a guest to the show
right and of course she doesn't respond
to anything but what do you make of the
fact that they can lay those claims so
easily and they're rewarded for it so in
other words if you were to do this on
the other side if someone on the right
was to say something like if you call
someone that's not a white supremacist
to whites residence that's almost as
damaging socially and and politically
and every other way as possible but if
you were someone on the right and you
said something that sounded off slightly
racially you get called a racist you get
fired and that's it
but Jamel Hill you know she works it at
the Atlantic no problem under david
fromm who sat in that very chair and
right and I think Jeffrey Goldberg's the
other guy and it's like you could say
what everyone now again you know my
policy on free speech so I'm not denying
her ability to say it I'm just saying
that the social yeah yeah so what do I
make it the social capital yeah
the way that we can use it
pending on yen's characters so but I
actually so I get what you're saying I
think I think it's true but only to a
certain extent and I think that the fame
and rise of Jordan Peterson proves that
it's only true to a certain extent
meaning sure from a social perspective
she has the freedom to make statements
which are not completely thought out
which are pejorative in a way and
disparaging in a way toward a person and
she can do so with out I mean she
obviously gets criticism but she can do
so without consequence basically I want
a certain level but I would say that
Jordan Peterson has a greater reach than
she does
Jordan Peterson has a greater I would
say growing fanbase than she does and so
I would question who has the more social
capital but is his social capital or
it's the capital of of ideas it's the
capital of good ideas sure sort of yeah
but I think that's I think that I think
that his social capital is a crewing
greater interest to continue with his
metaphor what can you do an impression
and I think that that will continue to
play out and I think that that actually
speaks to the fact that the right is
partially wrong when it talks about at
least within the context of Jordan
Peterson when it talks about the left
social capital because Jordan Peterson
is pumping up the Seattle Seahawks right
that's I don't think that's I don't know
if he would consider himself to be
right-wing but I don't I don't know if
that's happened on the right in a very
long time yeah I don't even I've been
traveling the guy for the last year like
100 shows I don't even know that he
considers himself part of the right I
think he's vaguely right cuz he's
vaguely conservative but I would say
he's really an old-school liberal yeah
that's been smacked around by reality
but in the way no he but but you know
serious heat also transcends these
labels and I think that that's his power
and and that's his social power and I
and that's what that's what I meant when
I said earlier I get what he's doing
because he is distilling things down to
their essence and and regardless of how
seemingly compelling the rhetoric of I
don't like this guy joining Peterson so
I'm gonna call him up Oh white
nationalist goes far on Twitter
his distillation and breakdown with
ideas and transforming those ideas into
lessons to live your life by will almost
inevitably always go go farther so I
would disagree with the premise yeah all
right I'll take that I like a little
silver lining you know I mean like that
I I will gladly take that all right so
let's spend a little time on where
you're doing most of your work now which
is advocacy for Israel now one of the
things that as a guy that voted Democrat
my whole life I can't really say I'm
part of the left anymore but but a lefty
my whole life until these last couple
years I would say one of the things I'm
most disappointed by by the modern left
is the just sort of unab and and hatred
of Israel this six-mile-wide absurdly
tiny country with no natural resources
in in the toughest neighborhood on earth
that's just trying to survive basically
but there's but I make sense within the
prism of everything else you've said
here related to intersectionality they
sorted don't like success and you so
they like minorities but they like
minorities when they're oppressed are
now thought of is no longer oppressed so
you automatically put them in the
oppressor category right now you've got
a country of these people that have
survived and not only survived but
actually thrive although there's Arab
Muslim members of the Supreme Court and
everything else but no they don't really
care about that so I don't even know
what my question is other than other
than like what is that it because it all
in some way it all just boils down to
that they just hate this tiny little
place that dares survive like I sort of
view it that way I think whenever you
combine the two processes of
caricaturing
and I have another one it's like when
you character to a caricature thing when
you turn things into a caricature and
when you well we'll just go with that if
your fundamental philosophy which and I
think intersectionality is this it
steams character during things then
inevitably oh this is the other thing
character chirring and conspiracy
theories you put that together you'll
get anti-semitism
yeah and intersectionality I've seen the
memes yes yes sexuality is a bit of a
conspiracy theory and it also
caricatures people and the characters
communities any caricature societies and
once you buy into that I think that you
will see of course Israel West is white
colonialists oppressor and Palestinians
is this brown oppressed right which is
both the caricature ring and a
conspiracy serious and and in conspiracy
theories you caricature people rain like
that sort of the process of how
conspiracy theories work can't deal with
depth of nuance or complexity and so
once this is your guy this once this is
your blueprint for understanding society
then you will gravitate toward
anti-semitism someone needs to tell my
brown Israeli brother-in-law but right
right right well this is the great irony
we don't understand history and you also
see everything through the prism of your
own misunderstood or your when you
understand everything or you see
everything to the prism of your very
small American lens meaning these people
grew up in America and they know that
America's problems have historically
been between black and white people for
example until they think that everywhere
else in the world all of the conflicts
that are going on are obviously also can
something to be divided along those
racial lines yeah ironically jingoistic
on some level or imperialistic to use
their to use the term yeah to see
everything through the lens into the
vantage point of your own reality or
historic reality which is what what
they're projecting wanted their underst
of Israel Israeli society not knowing
for example that the majority of Jews in
Israel are people of color not knowing
just to really get down to details that
laocoon party which is B B's party rose
to power because of its taking on the
challenges and the and the and the
interests of the Mizrahi community yeah
from North Africa right there there is
no like there is no understanding of
this reality because this reality cannot
possibly exist within an intersectional
is view of society yeah so in that way
it becomes the perfect test case right
for there's I would say basic struggle
for what reality is in a way or
something like that well struggle for
reality and ability again to deal with
jobs like I think that that's what this
boils down to Alton ultimately an
ability to deal with nuance and
inability to do with hue to deal with
human complexity the very complexity
that they themselves have and possess
and that's a skill set to be able to do
that right that's a virtue I think to be
able to do that and so it's not just the
fact that these two go back to students
are promoting something which is toxic
and bad it's also bad for them right
like they're not going to have a healthy
holistic life if they are unable to deal
with depth and human complexity do you
think it is also something I'm not
totally sure about this but something to
do is just the geographic size of Israel
like the absurdly tiny nature of the
borders that you could literally drive
both ways up north south east west
easily in a day you could drive all the
way north all the way back I'm sure in
one day I think it's about six hour
drive up north down south this way you
could drive like I don't know 15 times
in a day or something like that but that
it's so small that there focus on that
can become like even more of a laser
even though they make it seem like it's
just this my monstrous ever-growing blob
or something like that I
I don't know honestly III haven't quite
figure out the geographical piece to
this I don't know if it's relevant in
their level of analysis I think right
that's probably it's probably a little
too high level or yeah yeah I don't
think that really crosses their mind I
think that I think just once you see the
wealth of caricature and once you see
see yourself as living in this space
where everyone's against you then that's
easy to fall into this trap of either
anti-semitism are being very eerily
close coming it very early close to
anti-semitism so what are some of the
things that people say about you as you
have fought this battle because you know
look I can look at some of my some of my
other friends and former guests that are
black that have taken unpopular
positions related to the way black
people are supposed to think which is of
course inherently race yeah exactly so
the things that get said about larry
elder let's say were Tom his soul for
the last 50 years or my friend David
Weber or plenty of other people I know
you get a certain percentage of that
because when I was doing a little google
and idea people people say not nice
things about I mean it could be that I
just turned off my Twitter mentions and
sorry oh I mean honestly I if it is
happening I I think I have a filter and
it is happening right but I think I have
a filter I have filters put into place
and turned on that limit my seeing them
I I hate to sound like callous but I
just don't care meaning I think I think
that I used to bother me like in college
like someone was very pejorative toward
me someone was very racist toward me
because of my mind like calling me like
a slave and all these various things and
there have been other like I had a
desperate and I suspect this was a
tolerant lefty saying that because of
your views right I don't want to
caricature Dave according to what I'm
talking about this if ik person I might
think I'm right
sure yes
yes I don't want a character to the left
as this sort of like I know that was but
that's what we call an educated guess
yes he himself particularly yeah
happened to belong yes but but oh I had
a death threat also in college which was
it wasn't funny but it I don't know it's
kind of yeah that someone would take
such time to like focus his energy on me
which is a little weird but beside that
I just spend my time and my energy just
trying to put out good things into the
world and I think that because I focus
on that more than what the haters to the
speaker saying I just don't notice them
anymore and I'm just trying to go put
good energy out into the world to that
end you wrote your first piece in the
New York Times
how long ago about five six months ago
some like that yeah why I refuse is it
why I refuse to hate white people what I
want to get this right I'm sorry why I
refuse to avoid white people yeah I'm
pretty sure you're supposed to remember
what do you make of that title then
let's let's start that we cuz but a lot
of people don't know that that often you
can write an op-ed for for a major paper
and that you don't pick the title as
often people don't get past the title
right right I mean I don't have a
problem with it I think it was true to
the essence of what I was saying so what
was happening that I suspect it has a
lot to do with everything we've talked
about here but what was going on that
you thought that you had to write this I
mean this should be pretty obvious stuff
right I think there are actual pieces in
the New York Times or other people of
people of color were saying like I'm not
gonna have my child speak to white
people and I was like what there was one
I mean you're not making this up there
was one just a little bit before that
that literally was saying yeah I was
also having this intellectual fight with
him myself against uneasy coats and sort
of everything he stands for and like I
have a very strong reaction to that and
I think that this piece was the product
of all of those things and a response to
all of those things and the gist of it
was just that I grew up around all types
of people white people black people
Muslims Asia
I went to a very egalitarian high school
extremely girls are in so so the process
by which people again caricature
caricature each other in caricature
white people it's something that is a
very foreign thing to me like I don't I
can't quite wrap my head around that
sort of language that's used by people
who believe in intersectionality and
quite frankly by people who probably
have good intent like I'm sure the guy
who wrote that piece about having his
child of what white people was coming
from a place of a genuine in a sincere
place of concern so I don't want to like
disparage him in any way but I just
don't think you would say his answers
are confused yeah exactly but but
perhaps I would I would say that his
fear was probably real right so I think
that there's just a better way and a
more healthier way of going about these
things yeah
what do you think Martin Luther King
would would think about our society
right now there's a good yesterday
that's not you to tell the good people
you see I said I was preparing for
taping and I was doing so by watching
dr. King's speeches
that's so funny all right all right well
what do you think he would think of
things these days the state of the way
we we talk about race the people that I
think think they're his natural allies
are often using arguments that are what
I would say are a hundred eighty degrees
the reverse of what his arguments were
yeah dr. King I know this is almost an
impossible question it's a problem so
dr. King wrote a book called strength to
love which is a collection of his
sermons and I think in one of the first
a second like sermon slash essays he
talks about like why he rooted his
nonviolent movement
in this belief in concept of love or gap
a love love love for love's sake
essentially and I think that given the
fact that that he wrote that he wrote
that I think that he would definitely is
chew this new impulse within society to
reduce each other to immutable
characteristics I mean this is what he
was fighting against right but I should
say and right he would also have devised
a rhetoric that was strong enough and
compelling enough to inspire people to
aspire to loving each other and I think
that's that's actually what's missing
aside from a few different commentators
here and there who might be who sort of
exists in that I think the TED talk
circuit I don't think that there's this
movement within America trying to teach
people how to love and I think that
that's something we've lost and that was
something that was very central to dr.
King's writings and dr. King's work
again as I said earlier to devise a
blueprint where you say I am NOT going
to fight back against this white person
not just because non-violence is a very
strategic tactic but because this man
was made in the image of God like that
is existential and there is no
profoundly existential movement rooted
in love in the same way that it was when
he devised it in the 60s is that partly
because we've just made everything
political yes yes yes I mean it's become
like our identity right which is by the
way why I'm just like when you say like
the left and right like I don't know
these categories have to a certain
extent lost meaning for me and I say
that all the time and I think you can
even when I'm saying them there's a
certain exhaustion with okay sometimes
you just have to frame that you we just
need words you know it's funny you said
we've sort of lost the language to talk
about something stuff sometimes you just
need some labels
mostly to talk about these things
otherwise the people who can handle I'll
go with that but can you give me
something snappier can we get words to
make out a little snappier can you get
that in one bumper-sticker but that that
really is what it is I mean that also
explains the the explosion of these
conversations online because we're not
getting them through those videos I was
there friends and potential friends I
told you we were gonna end this with
love do you have anything else in the
love Department yes I think you nailed
it there and then I want to talk about
your website real quick yeah let's roll
them together right into that yeah okay
so one of the reasons why there are
negative conversations being had about
various topics various political topics
on college campuses and you know in our
political discourse in general it's
because of the framework in which that
conversation has had that framework
we've talked about is intersectionality
to a certain extent
intersectionality essentially encourages
people to make assumptions about each
other whether it's assumptions based
upon skin color what based upon
financial status or lack thereof based
upon gender etc so in order to challenge
the conversation or change the
conversation you have to challenge the
framework and the framework that
challenges intersectionality is the
theory of Enchantment and somebody here
has a website called theory of
Enchantment com what the hell's going on
over there so little bit of context I
was at the Wall Street Journal for a
year 2015 I was mentored by Bret Stevens
and part of my assignment was to develop
a paper and in this paper I was
essentially trying to figure out what
the psychology of connection was what
why do people gravitate toward with what
they gravitate toward and if I can
figure out the psychology of connection
or the science of connection and can I
use that science of connection to heal
disconnection and that is what ended up
being the theory of Enchantment and the
theory of Enchantment dry drives or
depends heavily upon pop culture
studying pop culture because pop culture
shows us what we gravitate to work so I
began to ask myself questions during the
course of writing this research paper
like why do we gravitate to our
companies like Nike what is it what is
it
that's love love it thank you but for
some people Nike is a religion like it
it's like on that level I'm like why do
we gravitate towards singer-songwriters
and influencers like Beyonce and people
would say well it's Beyonce it's very
obvious Chloe it's like no it's not it's
not obvious there's something happening
there and it turns out that all these
influencers and all these these
companies etc are doing one simple thing
they're creating content where their
audience sees themselves and their
potential reflected in the content and
that's how they're generating
connections so you wear that Nike shoe
because you think to yourself I wear
this Nike shoe I'll be able to just do
it when Beyonce says who run the world
girls women see themselves and their
potential reflected in that song so
either gravitates or her so how do we
use that basic idea to bring together
people who have been disconnected so the
theorem enchantment has three rules
three principles of trying to bring
connection in previously polarized
spaces and this can be used in
interpersonal conflict or conflicts of
other natures so the first rule is to
remember that we are human beings and
not political abstractions because the
first thing that happens in these spaces
we at least we abstract about each other
we think that we're talking to political
objects or entities and on a per full
person what I will do in a presentation
is I will point to a pop-culture
reference that illustrates this and I
usually point to Kendrick Lamar because
Kendrick Lamar has a song called DNA and
he says in this song I got power poison
pain and joy inside my DNA and what he's
doing when he says that is he is
articulating and illustrating what it
means to be a human being
we have all of these things within us we
have the capacity to do good we have the
capacity to destroy of the capacity to
build up right and we have the capacity
to tear down and just as this this
impulse exists within the person why I
disagree with I'm having a problem with
it also exists within me right I'm
realizing this is sort of the beginning
I think for empathy and mutual
understanding so that's the first rule
remember we are human beings not
political abstractions and as a
corollary we will not dehumanize or
stereotype or objectify any of the human
beings or any of the communities
involved in this conflict whatever that
conflict
the second principle is if you want to
criticize criticize in order to uplift
and empower never to tear down never to
destroy so if that person who believes
intersectionality is being very mean to
me and aggressive to me I could
criticize him by cursing him out right
by you know speaking down to him or I
can criticize him in a way that makes it
very clear that I actually believe in
his potential and actually believe that
he's better than the content or the
rhetoric the empty rhetoric that he's
putting out and by speaking in the
manner that suggests that I am more
likely to change him so quick story my
Angelou told this story about how she
she was on set with Tupac at a movie set
and Tupac was in the corner somewhere
cursing out this guy who he didn't like
and they were like about to get into a
fight and they might Angela says come
here come here let me talk to you and he
has Tupac series I hear he's like still
mumbling under his breath and then she
says come over here let me talk to you
and then she tells him don't you know
that we are counting on you don't you
know that you are the next generation
and and that we're looking toward you
it's a pains away for us don't you know
that you have been loved and we're
looking toward you as the next as the
next person to uphold us and so the
story goes that in that moment Tupac
starts crying mmm because she had rooted
her criticism in her fundamental belief
in him mm-hmm you know and then the next
day he's like he's sort of like kind of
still being aggressive toward that guy
and then Maya Maya passes and he goes he
likes trains up he goes good morning
miss Angela all right so he changed it
he modifies his behavior in front of
someone because she believes in him so
that's the second and then the third
principal the final principle is
everything we do we try to root and love
and compassion what sounds what sounds
very like you know fake but what it
means is if someone is being aggressive
towards your means words or whatever you
call that out as inappropriate you say
you know I don't know you from Adam I
don't know why you're prejudging me
which is the definition of prejudice
right but I'm not going to do is I'm not
going to prejudge you even though you
have prejudged me I'm instead if you
want let's go to this coffee shop and
let's actually talk
this topic topic X topic y whatever
we're having a disagreement over because
what's happening in that moment is
they're probably seeing you as a
political abstraction known as a full
human being you have to Ryu Minh eyes
that space and you and the purpose by
the way is not to get that person to
agree with every single viewpoint you
have the per the purpose of that is to
bring back compassion and empathy even
in the midst of profound disagreement
there's something we we are not doing so
well here in America so that's the
theory of Enchantment this has been a
pleasure
can you run for president or something
yeah absolutely not
that would not work with any of those
three pillars no it would I just I
prefer pop culture it's a political
culture yes that's the honest truth
yeah all right well I'm so glad we
finally did this and I will do it again
for sure and for more on Chloe you can
check out theory of Enchantment calm
[Music]